[Applause]
I I can't see ya
thank you very much for it is amazing a
word and when I got the first phone call
from Shawn I actually ignored it because
I thought it was a spam yeah I mean I
never I could never imagine I would go
this far so I feel honored were honored
to be with to be here with this amazing
talented winners yeah and I have to
thanks thank the school feature art for
summoning my film to this amazing world
my school did it for me I I was so busy
enjoying my free time after I finished
my film so high school theater for me
you don't my school I couldn't be here
and then I have thanks thank my
professor any Adam and grana and also
school steps Xiang India and Lotte
angeleka and also Terrence and thank you
very much for making my baby model for
my film her case and also my composure
and at the same time sound designer she
don't Kim thank you very much and lastly
thank you for or my family member for so
bring me by any means and thanks for my
friends thank you very much
[Applause]